he's the author of his new book off mike
and
also last week announced his retirement
it will be
a bummer not to hear him call so many
great events for the national hockey
league and for nbc sports
and he has done so much in his
incredible decorated career
mike emrick doc emerick here on the rich
eisen show how are you doc
richard how are you i am very well
michael thank you for calling
a question for you oh my gosh let's roll
what do you have
uh tampa bay lightning won the stanley
cup
and had their parade which was kind of
on the water downtown in tampa
so if the rays win yes we would gather
there might be some sort of a
replica of that but what would the
dodgers do
well as you know there is a river here
in los angeles but uh depends on the day
whether it exists or not
um in all the circumstances make it
really hard
you know when you don't win since 88
and you you have a celebration you would
want it to be something really special
but
how can it be with given the
circumstances uh
it's uh it's a tough thing i'm sure they
would enjoy
planning it but it would certainly have
to be
difficult no doubt that about that and
uh doc you bring up 1988
and certainly here in los angeles that's
a special year as you
we're remarking about uh the last time
that the dodgers won the world series
and it is also
uh famous for one of vince scully's most
uh iconic calls of
of the moment that gibson went yard uh i
i just want to give you the floor on
what your favorite calls
maybe of all time are of somebody else's
mike well that would be one of them and
here is the night
in 88 that happened bill clement
and i are at the forum in inglewood
across town yes describing the
philadelphia flyers
and the and the kings and
there's a a circled a circle defensive
zone pass between two flyers defenseman
and for a reason that we can't at the
time explain
an enormous roar goes up from the crowd
at the forum
and what has just happened is kirk
gibson's home run
and we don't know about that until later
on
and so that is why that
night still stays in my memory bank
because
it was one of those nights that you had
no idea what happened because it was an
inconsequential play
but boy the crowd was sure into it
weren't they you thought about that
and they erupted like crazy my photos
like maybe a delayed penalty or
something instead it was just a delayed
piece of information coming your way and
you know i
i again i just was wondering again uh
your sense
of uh another announcer meeting the
moment
knowing what it takes to actually do
that
yeah well that would be one of them and
i think any situation
where any guy that i've heard
got away and let the crowd do the
talking
and i i think that uh that same night
jack buck did the same thing
after he said i don't believe what i
just saw but
but to let the crowd do it and let the
guys in the truck
show the pictures uh that they are there
to show
i think that means a lot i remember
lasorda running from the dugout
and actually the camera jiggling some
because
how how the vibration within dodger
stadium was going
gosh i'm getting goosebumps and i'm not
even a dodger fan the pirates haven't
even won since 79 and that's my team
um it it it is marvelous though isn't it
that we the there was uh there was a
collection of
of uh highlights of all-time great uh
sports calls and the title of it was and
the crowd roared
and of course we missed that this year
in hockey we didn't have crowds but at
least there are some that are going to
be present at the game tonight
there are going to be some people there
i seem to hear the dodger fans a little
more
when when something good happens for
them but maybe that's just because the
microphones that i'm hearing are picking
them up more but
it's marvelous to think back during when
you're as old as i am
uh to think back during the time when
some teachers in your school would let
you listen to world series games
uh during school because we didn't start
having world series games at night until
1971
and so i was a part of that culture that
was
in secondary and junior high school when
it was just
understood that the good teachers the
nice ones would take
time out and you just missed talking
about school that day so you could
listen with the radio all the way up
to the world series and that day the
girls in the class would just have to
tolerate it
hall of fame hockey announcer and also
umpteen emmy award winner mike doc
emrick
joining me here on the rich eisen show
and we were just talking about iconic
you know calls and moments and you
mentioned jack buck his son joe
just had a wild wild end of a game
in world series game four over the
weekend and i'm wondering what
that would be for you in your career the
wildest finish you ever called
and you didn't see coming um and
and it happened what about for you doc
well we knew there was going to be uh
there was going to be an
end but with multiple overtime games you
just
never know there were two probably and
they were both four overtime games one
involved two of the greatest goaltenders
of all time both who
are in the hall of fame dominic kashuk
who was playing for buffalo
and marty brodeur who was playing for
new jersey it was in 1994
and it was a playoff series between the
two teams at the old odd in buffalo
and of course it went well past midnight
because it was four overtimes
there were 120 shots in the game and the
120th was the only one that went in
a guy named dave hannon scored it for
buffalo and it beat brodeur but there
were shots that went off the post stefan
richey of new jersey had a couple of
breakaways
was stoned on one hit the post on
another but
all night long no goals scored after the
warm-up that was it
until hannan scored and that was the
sixth game and that forced a seventh
game back in new jersey
of all things and dale howardchuck was
stoned by brodeure
late in the last 10 seconds or so of the
third period in a one goal game in new
jersey one
and eventually went on and faced new
york rangers but
the other one was the easter eve game
that bill clement and i were
fortunate enough to broadcast on espn a
game seven between the islanders and
washington
in 1987 and uh it went uh until about uh
20 till two in the morning
and uh it it was uh
a gallant war between two teams that
was going to be settled sometime and as
it turned out it was a wheeling
shot by another hall of famer pat
lafontaine that
glanced off the post and went in
and the islanders won the game and moved
on to philadelphia by bus
and played them just with uh with a
partial day's rest the next day
started the next round of the playoffs
but i think those two would stand out in
my mind for sure well they certainly did
and
and you know you have such a way with
words doc uh
it's it really is just wonderful to just
take in and listen to
and i'm wondering you know uh i i want
to give you the floor
on on this just in terms of exciting
moments in sports right
you've got to have something like maybe
uh if it's a running back or a wide
receiver that's breaking into the clear
or in baseball there's something hitting
the gap can it go for
you know second to third and can
somebody come home and
basketball it might be you know uh
the clock winding down and you know it's
the game's gonna be won or not for me in
hockey
it's the rush of the puck in a playoff
overtime i i i'm wondering if you would
agree with that and if so describe for
me what makes that so great since you've
seen it and described it so well for so
long
yeah i i agree with you and and what
often leads to that
which adds to the drama of the event is
when the goalie is pulled in the last
minute that gets the game to overtime
because
when the goalie's pulled a lot of times
it's one goal game and the ultimate
form of hockey's russian roulette where
you take a chance
to try and get the game tied in force
over time and
probably the best example of what you're
talking about and what i'm talking about
was the epitome of what i think hockey
was about
and it was seen by the largest audience
i ever got to broadcast to
27 million on the gold medal game in
2010 in vancouver
um the goalie was told in the last
minute and out of a
mouse scramble zach parisi of the united
states scored to force overtime
and then uh out of a half boards play
rather than an
end-to-end rush which is far more
exciting but usually with today's
defensive schemes it's not allowed very
much
the puck came to sydney crosby and he
was able to score
on ryan miller of the united states and
and win the game
in overtime and the gold medal to canada
but i think the thing that struck me
about that whole
event was it it really summarized the
best of hockey
and the greatest number of people got to
see the game and many of them were not
hockey fans on that last sunday of the
olympics in 2010
because pierre mcguire was not working
for us but had been during the whole
olympics
and so we had the rights to take his
interviews which were done for the
canadian network
with ryan miller the losing goalie and
with sydney crosby the winning goal
scorer
and the interviews that they gave were
typically gentlemen's interviews
praising the other team
talking about good things that happened
in the game
and really showed the best of what
hockey athletes are
and we got those on before the medal
ceremony took place
and many people that were watching the
end of that game because it went longer
than most games
got to not only see the winning goal but
also got to see
the conversations with two great players
and then
the closing ceremony took place uh an
hour two hours later i don't remember
the exact time frame
i was never prouder to be around the
sport and there been many times that i
have
than i was that day because so many
people got
to see the best of what this is all
about
the brilliant mike doc emerick a few
more minutes left uh here on our
conversation on the rich eisen show and
we
you know mike we take we take um
great announcers for granted we always
do it's just that
the big game that we love to watch so
much uh it comes on and we
we expect to hear the voice because it
makes us comforted to hear the voice
that it's
you know announcers become part and
parcel of our family in a way
uh and we sometimes forget it's a human
being that's actually
needing to prepare and needing to work
and needing to raise their game to that
level and
needing to get on a plane needing to sit
in a hotel or sleep in a hotel away from
family i mean
the great pitcher turned broadcaster don
drysdale passed away in one to be
you know fully honest and that's my
preamble to ask the simple question of
why
retire doc why now
um i'll try to uh answer this in the in
in a concise way if i possibly can uh it
came to a point
somewhere between the second and third
rounds of the playoffs that would have
been
shortly after labor day this year
that i was being so protected by nbc
and they had given me the right to stay
at home and work the first two rounds
as well as the option to stay at home
during the third round
and the final and i thought to myself
wow
they have protected me to the hilt here
and i'm completing
the 50 47th year broadcasting but the
50th year since i first covered an nhl
game
my 40th year of doing nhl television
and i have been blessed aside from the
cancer scare with good health
and here it is i'm 74 going on 75
my wife is healthy too this seems like a
very good time in my life to
to put down the headset microphone and
to
celebrate the years that we still have
of good health and god only knows how
many
months or years that might be and
also to look back with pleasure on the
many
people that have been able to help me
along
and get me the opportunities that have
led me to
walk in and get in free to so many
wonderful events
and so that's it at age 65
i got a chance uh to turn to the new
jersey devils who had been good to me
for 21 years and i followed them
uh with their games and at that time
not do their games anymore and that was
a hard break because
we'd been through a lot together but it
was a time when i needed to do less and
at age
70 nbc allowed me to do fewer games
as well i was doing two games a week
which involved
as you alluded to a lot of travel
because each game involved three days a
day to
travel so that i could do the practices
and the game
on the second day and then travel home
the third day
so six out of seven days to do two games
in a week and then uh at age uh
70 i dropped that back to just a game a
week plus of course
all four rounds of the playoffs and the
playoffs are very busy for two months
but that was fine because it's the most
exciting time
and then came this year when it seemed
like just the right time
to walk away so it is taxing but it is
fun and it does provide you with some
magnificent memories of times past which
i'm enjoying now
well and and times past and memories are
what this book is all about off mike how
a kid from basketball crazy indiana
became america's nhl voice uh before i
before i let you go um i you've been so
giving
to so many people you know all of us in
our industry
know um what many people might not is
you've given out your email address
publicly
to invite those who want to get in the
business to maybe find out how they can
become
uh a voice of a sport uh that they
didn't expect to be
when they were growing up in whatever
state they are in i'm i'm assuming this
book
lends credence to a lot of all that mike
yeah i still uh still get some uh
submissions from uh from various
announcers
some of whom are now because i've been
doing it for a while some of whom are
now in the nhl
i don't have anything to do with them
getting there you know rich if you have
the talent
you get there and if not you don't what
i've provided is what was provided me
40 years ago and that was an opinion
that maybe you can take the best of
anybody's opinion and learn from it
and through repetition and through
concentrating on your work improve
as the years go on but i am always so
proud to learn of someone who sent me an
email and i listened to their work
years ago uh earning a living in the
business because
it is wonderful isn't it you get a good
seat for the game
you get in free you get to work with
some of the best athletes
and then uh as uh your years go on you
get a couple of uh
checks in the mail each month or you get
a direct deposit into your bank account
and it's
it's just a wonderful way to earn a
living and i encourage people to do it
even though there's a lot of rejection
and you don't always get the jobs you
want uh don't quit
because if you believe in yourself and
have the talent you're going to get
there
well you've heard the cries for many
people certainly here in los angeles see
if vinn would do another inning or
another game and he has yet to do that
is there any
any thought maybe down the road you
would or is this it
you've called your last game you have
hung up your no this is
this is it but i am so grateful
to have gotten a phone call and i am so
sorry that i was not able to pick up
the phone call that i got on the weekend
and i plan to return it
on his birthday because he is a november
baby
and that was from vince is that right
you got a missed call from vince
i got a missed call from vin and the
first thing i'm gonna do when i call him
on his birthday is wish him happy
birthday and the second thing is to
apologize
okay well i'd love to be a fly on the
wall for that conversation and if you
don't mind i'm gonna keep calling you
and get you back on here because you're
just one of the greatest storytellers
and uh i'll i'll i will miss your voice
i'll be very honest with you so i
i'd love to uh you know give you that uh
invitation if you're willing to accept
it
uh as much as possible you you guys have
the number so please
don't be a stranger thank you thank you
right back at you mike doc
emmerich author of off mike how a kid
from basketball crazy indiana became
america's nhl voice
the hall of famer here on the rich eisen
show